completely off topic question is
Breaking Bad done good or bad for
chemistry
has it helped it or has it made it more
annoying
um
I don't know I mean I feel like we're
witnessing the origin story of like
future Walter rights is it like a meme
amongst chemists we talk about breaking
bad or was it just like a it's kind of a
thing where you roll your eyes yeah so
it's kind of it's like
I think Breaking Bad was I don't
remember the show enough I think it was
accurate enough in a certain way but
it's like if you do chemistry there's a
lot of stuff that I like the show I
thought the show was good and you accept
everything that comes with TV yeah but
it's like when other people kind of like
no I don't know how to describe
um
kind of like the the feeling right but I
guess maybe one thing would be because
like the math they made was blue yeah
and they'd be like Yo dude like could
you make super pure math and I was like
I mean in theory like any competent
chemist
Ry basic it's basic techniques like what
they did in the show were like very
basic techniques you're like averages
well no like straight up if you want to
know it's like the most basic technique
is recrystallization yeah which is like
if you know the solvent you literally
just dissolve it you heat it up dissolve
it and then let it cool down and the
crystals come out
and like for math not together are you
calling Walter White is Walter White
does Walter White look like an amateur
in the show then
uh no I mean they hiked it up to make
him look like you know really super
genius purifying a lot of these
chemicals is like very very basic
chemistry even like when you mentioned
before you're like oh you say
purification like it's normal yeah in my
lab we didn't trust even the chemicals
that were certified by the company right
because everything we did was like very
like
um not like it was very like sensitive
to water and air and stuff so we
re-purified everything and it's not
uncommon for labs to just purify
everything they get just to make sure
just to make sure it's full right right
so it's like all these techniques are
like very basic so it's like when people
ask me that I'd be like I mean anyone
who's done organic chem like it's maybe
probably gra even above ground like like
just undergrad yeah they could figure it
out like it's not really that
complicated but I was gonna say like
they go could you make the meth blue and
I was like what so what you want me to
do is contaminate it
because meth is white like it's clear
like it's gonna be it's gonna be like
most pure organic compounds are just
colorless yeah so to make it blue you
have to put food coloring in it right or
something so you're like can you make it
pure like make it blue and I'm like
that's an impurity yeah so like a stuff
like like it's not annoying but like
it's like this weird hype
about
um
it's like it's like this I don't know
how to like I don't know what the proper
term is for like people's view of
chemistry
yeah I really don't know how to describe
like the feeling yeah I feel like they
might have just like simplified it or
just summed it down maybe I would say
that it's kind of like this is a maybe a
bad example but like when people think
of Like a Surgeon or a doctor yeah it's
like if you don't know anyone in the
medical field they're just kind of like
these these Gods who are who just have
Infinity knowledge right right and
people kind of view that about chemistry
yeah that's weird to me about like
certain techniques where like I said I'm
like you take a cup of like at you just
pour acetone yeah you heat it up on a a
plate that gets hot you add stuff until
it stops dissolving
and then you just wait for it to cool
down and then it comes back out and
you're like well it's more pure now like
it's not really
um
it's not like this crazy like space age
thing but they would say it to me as
though like you could you could do like
this purification and I'm like I they're
not it's not very I'm not annoyed by it
but it's just like it's this like you're
talking about it like you're talking
[ __ ] yeah thank you no they're saying
things that are wrong I don't really
know how to describe it it's like it's
it's not a bad thing necessarily yeah
yeah that's what I'm saying like on one
hand it's like they're really interested
in chemistry but they're they're into it
in a way that doesn't really represent
chemistry I have a question it's not a
bad thing I want to know but I didn't
want to Google it because I I feel like
Google how to make meth all that like I
don't care I was like I didn't want to
see my history
you don't break your bed right this is a
scene and it stuck with me because I'm
like is that true it's like you've been
waiting for this moment I need you to
know and I'm sure the people who have
watched the VPN yeah
are sponsored if we if we actually have
an extra VPN sponsor this would be great
so there's a scene of Breaking Bad and
I've always wondered is this just
[ __ ] you know when they they want to
dissolve the body yeah and they have to
get a specific type of hydrofloric yeah
right and they have to get a specific
plastic is that true I just yeah so it's
that that's one thing I think I watched
The MythBusters thing where they tried
to dissolve it they dissolved a pig I
believe and it did work yeah but just
not like it did in right in the bag yeah
and it didn't go through the bathtub
exactly exactly so you could do it in
the bathtub normally so here's the thing
hydrofluoric
I mentioned the acid before right right
because I said it was one of the
chemicals I worked with recently that's
scary yeah you don't work with it
commonly like fluorine and hydrofluoric
acid are just not common could you get
enough theoretically to fill a bathtub
as well like is this it's hard like even
you could like a lot of these acids are
are industrial acids right because like
just like in [ __ ] Breaking Bad he
just gets it you're like oh worldwide
knows how to get a vat of acid it's
definitely like it it's one of those
things like even like cyanide as an
average person you're like I can't like
where do you even get cyanide if you go
to like some places that do like for
example a gold plated cyanide is used in
like gold refining and stuff they will
just have Drums of cyanide like just
like it's insane like dozens of like
just like thousands of pounds of cyanide
on pallets and stuff because it's
industry
and obviously you need it so obviously
when you're buying it it's not sketch at
all yeah that's why even in Breaking Bad
it's kind of realistic where he's like I
know where to get methylamine and he
like steals it from a company yeah
because it's like they do use it for
legitimate stuff and it's like you can
they will have tanks of hydrofluoric
acid that you could steal but it's like
ordering if I would be like I need a
thousand or a hundred liters of
hydrofluoric acid I don't I think you
can go online the companies the most
they cap out is like four or eight yeah
and it's like it's really I bought a 500
mL bottle because it's lab they all give
you like the high Purity lab right so
you want the industrial crap if you're
especially if you're gonna dissolve a
body yeah yeah but it's like if you get
the lab grade stuff it's like a dollar a
milliliter like it's really expensive I
was gonna say like is there like the
perfect crime in your head of how you
would do it because you obviously know
all these techniques right so like have
you planned like like I'm not obviously
you're not gonna kill someone for your
life
I don't know if I did it fully answer
your question that you had I think maybe
yes there's like is it true that there's
like Plastics so I should say that
that's what I should say it just says
that the uh whatever the last thing
hydrofluoric yeah dissolves glass
whoa so that's like what I I in a video
that's what I want to do it like show
right it's used for glass etching in
Industry so it's like very common which
is why I'm saying it's like an
industrial acid so people do it if like
sometimes I remember exactly like if you
need to etch glass to like Bond things
to it or to do like surface treatments
they will do a hydrofluoric acid rinse
first so it's really not uncommon but
you it's sold in plastic bottles so it's
like when it's a pain because when you
do any chemistry with it you can't use
glassware
how do you distill it you actually have
to use I think stainless steel like you
can't oh so you have to boil it right
yeah but it's called oil and plastic no
it won't it won't boil it's maybe some
high temperature but you wouldn't I
wouldn't do it in plastic but it would
just melt hydrofluoric acid though
think reacts with steel and iron to make
like iron fluoride but it blocks the red
I think it blocks the rest of the metal
from reacting all right it forms like a
passivation it could be wrong but it's
like that's not in my desk if it's in
the bathtub even if it like etches away
some of the surface yeah I think if it's
like a if it's like a steel bathtub or
certain Metals okay like it will get
stuck okay so all right I think I think
I could be wrong
I
have a body don't ask why how do I get
rid of it okay what I would do is I
would hang up
the police
um so you're asking how do you dispose
of a body what's okay in the movies in
the movies because I assume in the
movies it's all [ __ ] right yeah so
my my perception I've talked about this
before
I think that like just recently I think
we're in Japan talking about it right I
think anything like your problem is you
have a body right that is the problem
that's the problem that we're trying to
solve the solution is to not have a body
yeah right okay I think the more steps
you do in between is just you're leaving
more evidence
because I was gonna say like if you buy
the acid you buy acid right if you do
this thing you do this thing this whole
movie should [ __ ] right well I'm
just saying like if you go okay the best
way to dispose of a body I'm gonna chop
it up yeah you just get blood everywhere
it's like I just think that like I'm
just saying that like I feel like you
just are leaving a trail of evidence
behind whereas I watched like
what's like the dumbest thing I use well
I used to edit I I still at it but I
used to edit like and just watch
um a show a e I think there's no and ABC
2020. yeah which is just like murder
cases and it was kind of interesting
because they showed you like they
followed like from beginning to end like
the court case and everything
and what I kind of figured out from
watching it was the guys who got away
with the murder
put the least effort in getting away
with the murder oh just Chuck it in the
river or something well the guys who
were who are like trying to like stage
like a story and they bought fake plane
tickets and like did like all this stuff
they just got caught yeah because it was
so incriminating whereas like the people
who didn't get caught a didn't have
necessarily like a direct tie to the
person I was gonna say like I feel like
the moment you have a tie to someone
it's already problematic yeah but like
some of the ones that the people did
they just took the body drove to the
middle of nowhere and just buried the
body and like that it was just like
all right
it was like it wasn't like this crazy
movie scheme yeah uh there was even one
that was kind of crazy the guy just took
the body he lived near the desert just
drove in nowhere Nevada and buried the
body yeah right and they knew that I
think he had killed a couple people and
they literally spent like with hundreds
of people searching for like I think
weeks never found the body that's
[ __ ] Nevada yeah and what happened
though was they made it they cut a deal
with them because I forget exactly why
this is real right yeah yeah they cut a
deal with them because the families
wanted to know where the bodies were and
they knew he killed one person but they
could not get him on the murder of the
other two and they cut a deal with him
because there's no body they're like as
far as we know there's no crime and the
deal they cut with with him was if you
tell us where the bodies are to give the
family like closure we will not try you
for those murders and the family agreed
to it
where the body was and they found it but
it was impossible to find and I was like
the guy didn't have this crazy scheme he
just wasn't insane like trade-off for
I've ever heard no they said that the
investigator was like it was one of the
worst like offers he ever had to make
right yeah but he was like at this point
we were never yeah and guess what we
would never
he was never gonna get charged anyway
anyway yeah
um so at least the family gets closure
yeah but it's like if you have like a
place where there's like somewhere where
you can dump a body like bury it they're
like you just can't and it was it was
like not like it just wasn't a big
scheme right right I don't even know
it's just yeah just like there wasn't
this crazy like oh dissolve it yeah this
whole [ __ ] is just about a bunch of [ __ ]
but it's just like why dissolve it in
acid then you have a bathtub full of
yeah I was gonna say like like what do
they always I guess you could drain it
down but then all your pipes just just
because like when the plumber comes in
and be like hey uh
like uh it's gonna sound crazy but uh
we're drain cleaner were you using yeah
like I mean I'm sure there's some method
that you know some coming off camera
somewhere no I'm saying something some
criminal organization has perfected it
yeah but as far as I know I just feel
like everything you do you're dumb it's
not necessarily dumb I feel like you're
just just every step and thing you take
in between it's just more you could get
caught on I don't know what compelled me
yeah don't have a body yeah I was just I
was I just wanted to ask that question
because I was like I was like I wonder
if he's ever thought about it yeah okay
and that was how to get rid of the body
with now we're in everyone that is going
to be an interesting clip I've actually
never really put any real thought into
it I thought you're about to say like
I just imagined if you were watching a
movie and you saw it and you're like oh
this is not this is such a better way to
do it you gotta you know I think what's
kind of weird is like
I don't know I've just I've literally
never thought about it yeah correct like
I thought I think like you've passed
you're allowed back in the comments I
think like the the surface level I have
kind of just like
you see that yeah crazy asset and you're
like well that would be great like if
maybe that like if you vaporize a person
with that like maybe there would be no
evidence Left Behind yeah but I'd never
really like there was no thought after
like you know a fleeting force act